mr. Sherman you said a little earlier
and you have said in the past that the
Euro has become something of a failed
experiment here does that suggest that
you think the British are right to be
concerned about being in the European
Union leave aside the damage that may be
caused by leaving but do you have any
sympathy for the idea that they're
better off outside no there's a
fundamental difference between being in
a structure where everybody is forced
into the same currency irrespective of
differentials and culture economic state
it's in a variety of other things the
East the EU is a fundamentally a very
good idea it's a freezer
it's a free-trade zone structure which
we need an awful lot of so that the
choice of Britain to stay in the EU and
yet out of the eurozone was I thought
the most sensible action that could be
taken and Gordon Brown who was
instrumental in that decision I think
ought to be distressed by what is going
on as I know yes
well the question comes up if the euro
zone itself is failed experiment and one
of the problems they have is the lack of
a fiscal Authority the only way they can
get there is to centralize more power in
Brussels which is exactly what the
United Kingdom doesn't want well but the
problem with the euro isn't going to be
solved with that the problem with the
euro is much more fundamentally
difficult language which is going to
arise fairly surely let me suggest
something which nobody discusses as a
place and I think it ought to be
discussed if the Federal Reserve will
for example we should say if the Federal
Reserve were to run into financial
trouble and the dollar and very extreme
case the sovereign credit of the dollar
back we should say so which the Treasury
Department would back up the Federal
Reserve and they've been
problem there is no backup I'm European
central but right I mean theoretically
the Maastricht Treaty is God means by
which they would be financed that they
got into trouble but that's not gonna
that speaks to the fractious nature here
it it speaks to I think a Barry
Eichengreen at Berkeley talking about
the exorbitant privilege where's the
leadership to drive a solution we've
been saying this now for four and five
days we remember Valerie's you start to
staying Charles DeGaulle
at an hour of Germany I believe a name
Greenspan from the United States do you
observe leaders that can make tough
decisions as the acclaimed Chancellor
Merkel has made well yeah I mean Tony
Blair and Gordon Brown made some they're
not in office right now do you have to
say no and I don't see anybody to match
them so the basic problem is it's very
difficult for someone from the United
States no longer in government I don't
have direct daily contact as I did for
20 years you've not been speaking with
mr. Trump recently no what we may want
to get back we'll get back to the policy
later if you were still at the Fed it
you're going to your office a xx and C
Street on Friday how do you think about
it as a central banker you live through
market meltdowns before what's the first
thing you do what do you what kind of
conditions within your bank do you try
to establish well the first thing I
would ask is what is the cause of the
problem trying to ameliorate the
symptoms of the problem is never a
successful course because it doesn't get
at the root issue nobody is getting at
the root issue that confronts all of the
developed world which is as the fortunes
of the cause of the problem now because
what is happening is productivity growth
as you know for I think more than
two-thirds of the OECD countries is in
fact it's more than two-thirds
is been running at less than a half a
percent per year for five years
that means incomes of stagnating and you
see that in real as possible income
across England just like this absolute
dent and you know what about to say this
is a problem which is not strictly in
the United States right but as I said by
all the OECD countries and what that is
doing is creating a general stagnation
in the developed countries which is
caught which is causing desperation on
the part of their electorate I want to
go to the economic point of the last
number of days people linking currency
into interest rate into inflation into
declining GDP and it shows within a
reduced current account deficit for the
United Kingdom and maybe you bring up
the idea of a phrase from another time
to indefinite s-- greater fiscal deficit
tell us your experience with a nation
that has to work with a rapidly
worsening current account deficit well
usually the problem which you have is
only two choices one you flood the
particular problem with reserve balances
of some form or another irrespective of
where it's coming from or two you allow
the currencies to float the first is it
is obviously a desirable one if it works
but it's a risky one and you're always
better off to allow the markets to run
that course so in other words free up
the currencies free up very much the
actions which will allow a prices to
move if you try to stop prices you're
going to create huge problems and that
has always been my view as to what
should be done is there a risk though in
the UK situation to doing that when you
have a 7% current account deficit
there's a risk in doing anything the
question is what's the least worst risk
and what is it right now
I would say I wouldn't be that concerned
about the currency or because it's not
all that much you're going to be able to
do about it the currency remember is a
bilateral or multilateral extract rate
the effect of the two the pound sterling
against the US dollar that is as much
are doing as it is theirs and as a
consequence of that if you are dealing
up against a strong currency good luck
and I think that's why I suggest that
the worst thing you can do is futile
activities which seem to be successful
for the seem to be at least offices I
need to get you in trouble today then
what is what should the Japanese do with
a failed abenomics the currency goes
completely the other way of the desire
mister obey should they use the green
pen Greenspan prescription and ignore
100 yen or 95 yen or dare I say 90 yen
well I'm not about to give the Prime
Minister is a very thoughtful person's
advice on this and I just assume leave
it where it is at the moment you can
figure out where I come out I tried help
let me try and ask it this way as a
central banker during the period that
you were in office at the Fed when you
came to office intervention was a
regular practice of governments by the
time you left it wasn't being done any
more have we outgrown that as a tool I
hope so it doesn't work or don't well
consequence it it doesn't mean
distorting a currency for the purpose of
achieving stabilization is a loser's
game and the sooner you get the currency
adjusted to the marketplace then you get
the positive forces that people will say
my
god it's gone too far on the downside
let's come in on it
that's what you need which are debt what
you need now is all of a sudden the
pound to be undervalued well let me ask
this that do you have some sympathy with
the Swiss who are facing a tsunami of
money fleeing the eurozone and it's sort
of the only tool they have is to
intervene in their currency well yeah
but the problem is I mean what they're
ending up with is severe in negative
interest rates and what is fascinating
is the extent to which nobody can get
enough Swiss francs and they're not
enough Swiss francs out there to buy to
meet the demand so what you're getting
is that the Swiss regarding the holding
currency link in your world of economics
into the responsibility of any central
bank for the financial system to be
polite the banks are troubled this
morning in Europe what should mr. Draghi
do what should mr. Carney do frankly if
he keeps his job at the Bank of England
and other leaders do to support European
banks who seem to not be able to make
tough decisions oh when I was in office
I very much appreciated the fact that
Paul Volcker had never commented on any
of the monetary policies that the Fed
did when I was there that is an
extraordinarily useful operation to have
former central bankers like myself
second-guessing and carping on what
other shoe I should not do I don't think
it's very profitable actor because I I'm
all for to say I'm going to do financial
hatcher ahead of this week which I
switch gears a little bit please we were
talking earlier this morning about
whether or not the decision by voters in
the UK to take this leap is a sign that
globalization may have peaked and might
go into retreat at all if the the
benefits are so
a fuse compared to the very visible
losses that some people take that you've
come to a sort of a tipping point well I
think we're at that we're already moving
I mean it's just a matter of time before
Scotland gets another referendum because
it wants tonight it'll make it a lot
easier to stay in the euro and the
eurozone I'm sorry the EU whereas I
choose to do if in fact they don't have
to take too many actions freeing
themselves from the UK before the
article 50 takes hold
oh we're not getting easier for them to
stay there so I think that we're going
to get very extreme they significant to
renewal of the referendum on Scotland
and I'm almost certain it's going to
pass
does it go does it then spread to other
European countries you can't stop the
march of progress as it were my hand
through a lot of sand into the gears I
think the vulnerable institution right
now is in eurozone because as I said
before there is no backup to the ECB yet
European Central Bank assets which had
gotten up to a high level and then came
all the way back down has now come all
the way back to the height of where they
work that had raised serious questions
of what happens if all of a sudden the
Euro ceases to be a hard currency it
happens overnight there'll be very
significant difficulty as far as I can
see and I think the thing to do is what
they should have been doing a long time
ago get Greece out because if there are
toxic liability sitting in the middle of
a very important economic but is it just
Greece or would you have to get rid of
Portugal or maybe even Italy I think it
depends on them in other words
theoretically if you ask me what would
the euros
basically exists of Germany and the
Netherlands Finland all currencies which
the best way to put it is when the
crisis happens they all move together
then are we seeing a death to forget
about the European experiment or Monet's
action are we seeing a death of the
Washington Consensus here in the
Atlantic Charter to President Bush
senior's work with GAD and trade is this
referendum the first signal of the death
of your Washington Consensus well it's
too soon to say and certainly that this
too strong word it's absolutely needs
readjustment in the euro zone cannot go
on structurally the way it's put
together now it's fundamentally the
northern states of the eurozone funding
the southern states and the result of
that is you have an unstable system
which cannot go on indefinitely and you
need confit that you're going to put
more than one currency together it has
to have a similar culture you cannot
have intellectual cultural now you know
the argument I used to get is that when
the Europe comes in the Italians would
behave like Germans they never did from
day one is the United Kingdom a
differential culture from Germany most
certainly in the sense that in that
Kingdom is sort of a hard to define it
it's not in its coming off of
generations of squeezing down from
British and part jump are in 1913 was at
its peak and World War one a very great
damaged World War two obviously
significant and
or not for Margaret Thatcher coming in
oh when she did and do did what she did
it wouldn't be in as good shape as it is
today and remember that when Labour came
in after Thatcher and Tony Blair and
Gordon Brown didn't change anything
what Thatcher did what can the next
president do to assist europe is immense
challenges Lord Brown of petroleum is
adamant that the United Kingdom had to
remain because of tensions from 70 years
ago the outcome of World War two how can
we assist Europe stay away from those
primeval tensions I wish I knew the
answer but when killing now and very
early days prices which is about a way
to go I mean this is physical we've
triggered a series of bends here which
when Scotland where Scotland does
Northern Ireland to be clear you're
predicting that Scotland back to 17 I
believe oh three will leave United
Kingdom yes
Northern Ireland as well
well Northern Ireland probably got the
same not the same type of problem
remember Scotland wanted to become an
independent nation because it had oil
above all that oil in the North Sea
right by the time they finally got to
the referendum that the whole reserve
was almost gone it is gone now so the
economic problems that Scotland's going
to run into well if I say when it moves
I'm going to be very difficult I think
because they don't realise the extent to
which you white always funding them and
it's going to be it's going to be a lot
of wrenching things are going on I want
to tease forward to our next section
we've got about two more minutes
chairman and move on to more mundane
ideas where are we in the debate the
Battle of rules versus discretion give
us an update on where that is is we
prepared for our next discussion I'd say
the discretion that won today because
every time you try to lock in some rules
you get them locked in incorrectly
because you can't anticipate other
markets going to behave well there's
still a movement on Capitol Hill I do
what the Federal Reserve into rules
based procedure what would happen if
that were acid
well we would find ourselves on support
the currency and an unsupportable
position is it the legislative version
of going back on the gold standard no if
we went back on the gold standard and we
adhered to the actual structure of the
gold standard as it existed shape prior
to 1913 would be fun remember that the
period 1870 to 1913 was one of the most
progressive periods economically that
we've had in the United States and that
was a golden period of the gold standard
so I think that it's I mean I'm known as
a golden blog and everyone laughs at me
but well why does central bank's own
gold now why just well we're going to
come back on that we could talk forever
about this Alan Greenspan Gold Bug with
us
today our guest Alan Greenspan who I
doubt needs any introduction Mike why
don't you start with chairman Greenspan
thoughts on the why we're here
well that's an interesting question
because you have noted and back in March
when Tom and I last spoke with you you
noted at the time that there is
something beyond the individual
day-to-day news that we are watching
it's a deterioration in the standards of
living that people have these days that
is around the world it's global and that
is leading
to symptoms like what we're seeing in
the United Kingdom that aren't the cause
themselves well I think the problems
that we have as I mentioned before is
the fact that well it's cool it's you
know it's often useful to start with the
end result and go back causation in
Reverse of what we see is a desperate
population out there everywhere we're
seeing it in the United States you can
see it all during our election period
it's a fear it's a desperation they're
looking for somebody to come and help
them out that is a similar thickness is
basically what brexit is and all about
we're seeing it in Europe generally and
so the question is why well nobody
wishes to discuss this because it's
politically very difficult to discuss
because nobody knows what to do about it
in the United States which is not by
itself by any means in fact the u.s. is
better it's best to talk about because
our data system is better but what I'm
about to tell you exists pretty much
throughout the developed world and that
is that as the populations age and they
all are now in their baby boom period
any further going into retirement that
is creating a major fiscal problem in
all of these countries and the issue is
essentially that entitlements which are
entitlements are legal issues they have
nothing to do with economics you reach a
certain age or you're ill or something
of that nature you're entitled to
certain expenditures out of the budget
without any reference to how it's going
to be funded where the productivity
levels are now we're lucky to get
something even close to 2% annual growth
rate and that annual growth rate of two
is nine adequate to finance the assess
your experience can policymakers adjust
productivity higher no they can
indirectly I'm sorry if they were to
slow down the rate of growth of
entitlements and enabled remember in
what's happening which is a remarkable
statistic for the United States the sum
of gross domestic savings plus
entitlements as a percent of GDP is flat
for a half-century that means that
basically every dollar of entitlement
crowds out crowds out one dollar gross
savings the gross savings adjusted for
the current account balance is that what
gross domestic investment is but
critically your ten-year shows and I
think of Tip O'Neill as well speaker
O'Neill nothing gets done without crisis
I'd you just does Alan Greenspan just
wait for the next crisis without Capitol
Hill doesn't I said in a book I'm
finished recently so I don't know how
it's going to resolve but there's gonna
be a crisis she said that in the last
book well I'm waiting head he was right
he was right why these solutions come on
the fiscal side yes how did it and it's
not like people on Capitol Hill or
people in Westminster don't know what to
do they don't want to do it what's the
communication to how do you tell them
how do you get through to them about
these issues this is one of the great
problems of democracy and it goes back
to the founding fathers how you handle a
situation like this and it's very
troublesome but eventually you get
things like Margaret Thatcher showing up
in Britain their their situation is far
worse than ours and what she did is she
turned it all around
essentially by as I remember it
as the the the miners work who were
going to strike and she decided that she
knew they were going to strike since at
that point the government owned this the
coal mines she built up a huge inventory
so that when they went on strike there
was enough coal in Britain so that
eventually the whole Union structure
collapsed that put her on a whole
different oh she changed she
fundamentally changed Britain to this
day I mean the fact that we're doing so
well in the EU it's not altogether clear
that it is the EU or whether it was
Margaret Thatcher what do we need then
an accident of history up probably I
don't see because in the United States
social benefits is we're going to which
is the more generic term or entitlements
are considered the third rail of
American politics you if you you touch
them and you lose now that is a general
view to Republicans I want to touch it
the Democrats the one who touched it
right then I want to talk about it this
is what the election should be all about
in the United States it will never hear
one a word from you this alan greenspan
where this is Bloomberg radio in
Bloomberg television worldwide we need
to do a data check and it's a
deteriorating tape- 2:11 on the Dow
17,000 189 the VIX adding more than odd
today 24.70 just simply the mathematics
there is a bit out of kilter to say the
least sterling with a modest bid 130 to
43 off a very very difficult morning as
well did you read Mervyn King's book
yes what do you think I thought it like
everything Marvin can Gaza resplendence
what would Mervyn King do and what would
you be your advice for Governor Carney
and I don't mean in terms of do this
raise rates and all that because I know
you're not going to answer me but to set
the tone because a lot of this with
Margaret Thatcher and with Sir Winston
Churchill was to set the tone how do you
set the tone
what would Mervyn King do what would
Alan Greenspan do you threw in a monkey
wrench oh that would last fretful last
right that's a hat trick now but but
seriously I don't use to be said I don't
know for the first thing you do is which
is what we always did know how to crisis
we get together the g10 or the g7 or of
bilateral meetings much of what goes on
in such economic meetings you never hear
about and it basically requires
sometimes a judgment of trading off one
terrible thing versus another
I hesitate to give anybody any advice
first of all they have access to far
more information than I do now to be
sure most of what's available is
publicly available but not all and I
know that it's a critical difference
secondly I like Paul Volcker's basic
view of people sitting on the sidelines
have you been around and writing advice
as some it's a hatrocks official
hatrocks yeah we're going to switch
topics a little bit here talk more about
the US economy when I was a Fed reporter
chasing you around the halls of Congress
we used to always talk about what was
Alan Greenspan's favorite indicator of
the moment there was a scrap-metal there
were railroad car loadings give us your
view now on the outlook for the US
economy and what you're looking at that
tells us that tells you well the
fundamental issue is the fact that
productivity growth is
ground to a halt uh we're running out of
people in other words everyone is very
pleased in fact that the employment rate
is rising well the statistics tell us
that we need more and more people to
produce less and less and that is not a
prescription for a viable political
system and so what we have at this stage
is stagnation I don't think that there's
anything out there which suggests that
this recession but I don't know that
what I do know is that the money supply
m2 has always been a critical indicator
of inflation is for the first time it
was growing up remarkably steadily six
seven percent almost a straight line
it's tilted up in the last several
months it's at a percentage point or two
the thing that we should be worrying
about now which we have actually given
no thought to whatsoever is that this
type of economic environment ends with
inflation historically fired money has
always ended up that way I'm going to
get a lot of letters when you say your
people who were going to say what's he
talking about there's no inflation the
market see no inflation futures
indicators show no inflation how do you
defend your cork to be more blunt are
you an inflation ISTA that's the voices
all I'm saying is I don't know when it's
coming
I know if you look at human history
there are times and times again when we
thought that there was no inflation and
everything was just going for and I just
basically say wait this is not the way
this thing ordinarily comes out I don't
know hm-hm I cannot say I see it on you
idiot arise and in fact commodity prices
of
sadi the oil price has been a terrific
impact at a terrific impact on global
inflation it's not about to emerge
quickly but I would not be surprised to
see when the next unexpected move to be
on inflation side you don't have
inflation now and you don't happen to it
happens how do you respond to Paul
Krugman's essay the other day that
there's a glory to simple models he goes
back to Hicks 1939 and he's got a chart
from a live able and charter net but
like you from a different angle
it's how I'm going to I'm going to lump
greenspan with Krugman it's never been
done but but but if I take Paul Krugman
and Alan Greenspan's primal cry we want
simple models is our solution now to
think simply or is there a value to the
complexity of globalization and the
complexity of institutions which way
should we turn now oh you you want to
have a simple model that you can get
that actually captures the complexity of
the forces that are in played to get
simple models merely takes it to secures
slim them down easy to do but they may
not worry do they work with negative
interest rates and other distortions of
this financial system like this is well
the argument that the bill Dudley of the
New York Fed said is that DSGE models
that you use in phurba s-- the the feds
model don't do well at incorporating
financial markets into their mana to
correct in other words the furbished
model purposes FRB us that model works
exceptionally well for the non-financial
area I had many inputs myself I worked
with it very closely on my sideline was
even a metric so that I you know argue
with the people there on the key values
and everything else like that but the
financial model was awful
it captured nothing it didn't grasp what
the issue is and I try to reproduce the
right to what I would do is in the map
in the territory 2.0 which is the latest
version of that and I demonstrate that
what we have going that we don't measure
correctly of bubbles and their
implications bubbles per se are not
toxic with the mm bubble collapsed we
barely could see the change in economic
activity on October the 19th 1987 the
Dow Jones went down 23% in one day you
will not find the slightest indication
of that collapse and that bubble in GDP
numbers or in the industrial production
or anything else so I think that you
have to basically decide what is causing
what I think the major issue in the
financial models has got to be to
capture the bubble effect bubbles are
essentially part of the fact that which
human nature is not wholly rational and
you can see it in the data of very
clearly one one question if I may to
stay away from Fed policy negative
interest rates I don't believe they are
in your textbook at NYU we are learning
about negative interest rates what have
you observed and what we see if we see
even deeper negative interest rates in
the coming months
well let's understand where negative
interest rates come from if you go back
and look at the period when say that US
10-year note was 5% or thereabout
or when a normal relationship existed
negative rates would not exist but if
you take for example when they emerge
you have saved 5 10 years ago
Swiss franc so I should say that the
yield on Swiss long-term debt would be
two three four hundred basis points
under for example in Italy Italy or
other less desirable and that spread
would move up and down and now it's
broken
well no it hasn't broken what happened
is that if the overall rate comes down
then in order to keep that spread the
Swiss franc has to go negative now and
so that what you have who said it can't
now they're going to start they're going
to start them it stock up on currency
and it's going to make a difference
we've run out of time we could go
forever particularly on the united
kingdom alan greenspan thank you so much